how about working on Magic Mike that has
got to be interesting experience because
you're on this set with these guys who
are walking around wearing next to
nothing
yeah bongs yeah men in thongs yeah and
it must be nice to switch the sort of
gender stereotype you get to objectify
them exactly it was really nice you sort
of really nice to objectify man yeah no
it was amazing it was hilarious we just
heard of like they did the dances and I
wasn't in the scenes but I would just go
in the back of the room and just like
laugh and watch you would laugh it just
seems it's funny because women sometimes
when they see when when guys are looking
at a woman in that situation they they
get you know kind of creepy or they
stare I'm just channeling my own
reactions but women they let it laugh
and they get like aggressive yeah oh
they get on stage and like they're it's
like yeah it's funny right but not you
you just wow I was just laughing okay
that was nice of you not to get
aggressive
you